what's going on there citizens of the  reject nation top gun maverick is now  out on digital release real rejects got  sent some goodies privileges  oh yeah  tom cruise smile  oh sweet aviation glasses  try putting it over my actual glasses  yeah whoa  baby look at that  look at this yeah when i fly the skies i  can  pack my my lunchables with me from  boater skins whoa what a nifty jacket  holy balls oh my god what a jacket this  is  i believe the term that was just fed to  me off camera is a bomber jacket perfect  time for the for the summer  for the hot california heat i don't  think i've ever had so much sex appeal  yeah all right guys well top gun  maverick now out on digital still in the  theaters thank you paramount i love your  movie a shill for your film